lutter contre les populismes merci la
parole est à monsieur yves censi merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
un nouveau passage en force de votre
ministre de la santé
cette fois pour nommer un membre de son
cabinet comme directeur adjoint de
l'institut gustave roussy a suscité
l'indignation de la communauté médicale
certes avec sept nominations de
complaisance
la ministre ne freine pas la loi puisque
un décret de 2010 y autorise mais elle
enfreint toutes les règles d'usagé des
tic partagé par le corps médical
dans ce genre de nomination d'autant
qu'elle concerne le plus grand centre
anti cancer en europe regroupant
quelques 3000 salariés 300 chercheurs
pour une cause éminemment stratégique
que dans la recherche et la santé
publique
alors c'est choquant car le conseiller
de madame touré ne répondent même pas à
la fiche de poste qui stipulait
expressément une grande expérience de
terrain dans le milieu hospitalier
c'est choquant car vous êtes vous vous
asseyez sur l'avis négatif du directeur
général de l'institut qui est soutenu
par la communauté médicale
c'est choquant car le conseiller de mam
touraine années déjà à sa deuxième
tentative de recasage après un essai un
échec au chu de pontoise sans compter le
jeu de chaises musicales pour libérer la
place de l'institut et assurer le
placement des proches de madame touraine
dans différents chu
alors monsieur le premier ministre
prépare et vous l'avenir de la recherche
française ou préparez vous l'avenir des
copains et des affidés qui ont décidé en
nombre de quitter un navire
gouvernemental à la dérive depuis le
renoncement de françois hollande
cet épisode renforce l'idée que vous
seriez l'exécuteur testamentaire du
président de la république change et de
distribuer les postes avant la grande
débâcle
ce n'est pas à la hauteur ni de votre
réputation ni du centre anti cancer ni
de notre république
ce matin c'est le conseil
d'administration de l'institut qui a lui
aussi rejeté la nomination du candidat
demain
n alors monsieur le premier ministre
allait vous en tirer les conséquences et
demandé à votre ministre de mettre fin à
ces pratiques
unanimement contestées merci la palette
en date dans les sols twem ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur a fait le plein pour les
codes-barres et son gros défaut de
réponse aussi de quoi vous plaint du
fait que je propose la nomination de
monsieur frédéric wargnier qui est un
directeur d'hôpital
ayant occupé les fonctions de secrétaire
général du grand hôpital du sud
francilien pour occuper un poste de
directeur d'hôpital
de quelles procédures administratives
parlons nous d'une procédure qui a été
élaboré par le gouvernement fillon
précisément ad-hoc pour l'institut
gustave roussy et puisque vous parlez de
l'usaj monsieur le député je tiens à
vous dire que cette procédure a été mise
en place le sous l'injonction du
prédécesseur du poste à pourvoir et que
d'ailleurs à l'époque les professionnels
de gustave roussy avait déjà marqué une
certaine inquiétude
avant de travailler fort bien avec le
prédécesseur à ce poste monsieur
guépratte le directeur de l'hiver a
souhaité de son côté organisé une autre
procédure qui 1 par ailleurs abouti à ce
que monsieur frédéric variés soit classé
dans sa short list donc ses compétences
ne sont pas en cause mais je voudrais
vous dire monsieur le député que je ne
vous ai pas entendu quand j'ai nommé il
ya quelques semaines un ancien
conseiller du cabinet de madame bachelot
à la tête du chu de nice
alors que sur place les professionnels
avaient un autre candidat je ne vous ai
pas davantage entendu monsieur le député
lorsque j'ai nommé
d'anciens conseillers de cabinets de
l'actuelle opposition respectivement
numéro deux de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament et directeur de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation et je ne vous ai pas
davantage entendus lorsque j'ai conservé
à son poste
le l'ancien membre du cabinet de
monsieur sarkozy qui est un directeur
d'administration centrale depuis cinq
ans dans mon ministère
salut mais la seule chose qui compte
pour moi merci madame